So this quiz was probably little tricky to answer based on just what I've told
you so far and the picture might be a little receptive. But I hope you thought
about this from the perspective of constructing a program. The answer I think is
correct is that it's not the case that all modules should be of similar size,
it's okay of they are like shown in the picture, but this shouldn't be a big
design constraint. It's okay if the sizes vary, and in a typical program we'll
have some small modules and some larger ones. The second answer is true. Our
goal in using modularity is to manage complexities. So we want to break the
program into pieces small enough that one programmer can understand and build
them. Note that if we're a very large program. This may require hierarchy. We
might need modules of modules. The third answer is incorrect. If they're no
dependencies at all between the modules, well that means they're not working
together. In order for the modules to work together there's has to be some
connections between them. What we want is for those dependencies to be
manageable. We want there to be small Well-defined interfaces between the
modules. That means that in order to use one module, what we need to understand
about that module is as little as possible, but enough to be able to use it to
build something useful. And that's going to be one of the main things we focus
on in this lesson. One of the advantages of having narrow well-defined
interfaces is we can separate the implementation from the use of the module.
That if we have some other way of implementing this piece, well, we could still
plug it in and we wouldn't need to change the green piece at all. That's one of
our goals of modular design, to be able to plug in different modules without
having to reconsider the whole system.